we can easily the world I think the real
issue here is that we need to recognize
that Asia is already eating more it is
not about geography of boundaries Asia
is right now in Silicon Valley Asia is
happening in Europe Asia is permeating
the planet as we spend so the question
should not be so much about better Asia
is leading the world it's question is is
Asia leading the world in the right
direction and the right direction is
something that we have to define we have
to set into place there are things that
is your brains that adds richness to the
world per se and changes it is the
cutting change of chair of everything
that's happening right now it's the
cutting edge of change the challenge is
to recognize whether this is going to
add do its you know the growth of
humankind what we need to probably
question here is Asia leading the move
in the right direction and Asia has a
lot in terms of history in terms of the
fact that we are bringing in great
diversity we're bringing in a lot of
culture all of the world's religions in
essence startin Asia be it in the Middle
East or in India Asia has a richness in
terms of work ethic it has rich listen
in terms of education but most of all
its greatest strength is in its
spirituality and there is a difference
in how work is done here as opposed to
address the world there's a difference
in how the family unit functions here as
opposed to press the world and most of
all I think there is difference in the
way attitude towards life to its success
is issue is looked at here as opposed to
resp remote so it is the ease in
millennium and the world has to wake up
to the fact that they have to work and
live according to Asian values and Asian
percepts because this is where
everything is going to happen in the
next century yourself and I would like
to receive those leaders who are going
to be
having the time to look into this to
consider how the impact of Asia on the
development of all is going to change
the growth of mankind to say and that is
the real question is Asia going to lead
the world in the right direction